[Music]
whoa talk about deep cut you know I
never liked my birthday especially I
turned 49 you had to throw you a parade
one year yeah but it was just fun for
the show but I always I always hate it
why because you're getting older I mean
the option is though not turning 49
which means you're dead so better older
than dead sit yeah I mean that's how you
start to look at that saying are you
getting older when you start to go like
well the option there's one other option
didn't you got Liv some of your friends
that's cool a lot of my friends yeah
that's pretty dope yeah I mean it's you
feel bad about outliving your friends
and you feel good about it you should
feel good it's a competition anyway it
is young you know are you how do you
think your 40s have gone you know I mean
they were fine I mean they were I mean
I'm still working hey Mark yaar Norman
how are you better than your 30s
um career-wise yeah of course I did
three specials in my fortune that's
what's out yeah and I mean may or may be
94 right so yeah I think that uh hey
Mark you know everyone's uh someone said
who was I talking to this did you like
an encyclopedia of people's bits meaning
that you've watched a lot of comedian
like your girl oh okay I think Sam
Darrell said that oh yes
so if I have a joke or something I want
to bounce off you you'll know if so yeah
okay I'll do it you hear a couple of
thoughts out there haven't asked okay I
called like a town I called a couple
people there like a mark might know cuz
he sees everybody stuff oh yeah
Jim is tired today cuz he's been flying
all night but he's also 49 years old
today oh you know tired 49 49 yep that's
pretty good yeah by the youngest guy at
the Sabbath show man oh no they attract
people of all ages thank you they
attract younger people and older people
it's really an amazing place to be I'm
glad I'm glad you brought some facts
into that yeah when it comes to Sabbath
you gotta keep everybody [ __ ] what's
the same where that his late at yeah
what's the deal with Sam Worthington we
were nine but it's actually 9:30
Wow so that whole go to break thing the
whole yeah we got
'we all ricky said ok ok it's ok guys so
should we celebrate then what sort of
celebrate we can do a little celebrating
all right and then other celebration
later yeah ok what's other so let's
begin the celebration let's begin the
celebration okay hang on who who has who
has something that they'd like to share
with Jim dude me but he's making peepee
okay now do I know Alina is Alina back
yet no she's getting Jim a cold brew ok
so that's my birthday gift
town a [ __ ] she paying for it wait this
hotdogs have anything prepared he said
he said the other games I sign he had oh
my god hotdog is saying that his gift is
delegation yeah he delegated that sign
sign we have a happy birthday Jimmy sign
it's good they keeps going but it keeps
going off the screen yeah I also tweeted
a gift that handsome Rob made I don't
know if you saw I did not but handsome
Rob made the sign mm-hmm so what a
hotdog do he delegated oh he said make a
sign without him there would be no sign
did hotdog tell him to make the sign
after he already made the animated gif I
mean he made the animated gif on Friday
like I've had it over the weekend he
just handed to me my gift it's 49 year
old joke because cute unwrap it yes so
it's not even an original idea like he
saw okay he made a gif so you should
also just make a sign yeah that's not
really he was gonna do it but that's not
really a good gift
no I start at all you didn't like you
know thought to it you have a song or
anything you could sing to Jim why
didn't you what you were going to do is
not relevant it was going to Yoda would
hate this thing
not talking to a microfiber where does
Radio hot dog yeah thank God for Troy at
least somebody got a brain in their head
around yeah we're gonna go get a card
during the break no you weren't you
don't get credit for the car by saying
you were going to get it
I still AM anyway and it already we just
did the break I'm still going I don't
like your glasses by the way you look an
African dictator and there's glass I
will say it's good to see some ugly
radio guys again by the way you know how
I know he wasn't planning to get a card
how do you know this he's been sitting
here for hours it's not like Travis
Travis knows about my birthday Travis
talk about what you did my birthday put
in the shame I can't tell you yet
I see gifts your gift is coming later
yes oh boy that's a nice pile over there
young yes it is hot dog did you did you
just make it out
did I make what up that you were gonna
get him a card no I was gonna get him a
card when next break you got here like
yeah it's 9:15 deep in here for two
hours I was gonna get a condom but I'm
not asking what you're going to do I'm
asking when when was the plan and don't
say Oh coincidentally right now
yeah I was I was just saying around for
a little bit too long you talk about
apartheid when when did you think you
were gonna go get the card yeah like
during this past break but then I you
guys I just sat down and you thought you
had to catch up on your sitting well cuz
I figured they needed a phone screener
after only knowing you were correct yeah
for the break but you couldn't just
count one yesterday mm-hmm
yeah Sam I don't course Mew Oh would you
get him nothing
Sam got a haircut yeah I got it haircut
you know what I have for you today that
haircut by the way is upset horrible you
know what I have for you what a great
co-host well where is he
Oh Troy Travis did you tweet a photo is
that a haircut for me for today yeah did
you just get that it's your birthday
haircut wow it's very upsetting that's a
problem Anthony Anthony sir Anthony
would you have something you'd like to
present Jim oh the gambling addict yeah
yeah yeah Anthony got called up
Friday finally just walked in and shot
himself I didn't get you anything I
didn't get you I didn't know I wish
somebody were told me would you've got
him a card
yes oh my god another another pound cake
bye mother
ah it's a cumbia cake so Anthony he
brought in another pound cake
what is that shape yeah it looks like
bear meat what is that yeah she took her
own suggestion of using a smaller cake
pan and that's what comes out he did
that on purpose she said she had to she
did not could not have done that by
mistake she should not be very proud of
this cake no she's not yes she is she's
not that cake or her semi more for
something you're not proud of that cake
I am it's gonna be good lately try a
little nibble of it I need a knife of
some shoes all right she put that in the
pan it's not all right mark it's [ __ ]
burned on the top it's like French bread
when you get in the middle of it it's
golden brown very golden brown the me
can you grab him a knife Troy I got one
oh you got one okay guys just don't
touch you with your hands um I want your
little dick beaters all of my treat it's
Anthony your cake is not the shape of a
pan on my cake just stop
you're our pants made of oh my God look
at him Freddie exactly you bending the
knife in it's metal he can't get through
it by the way stop stop being half way
through one minute you're like I approve
is this cake okay yes but thanks it next
minute you're saying it's but it's not
my cake the middle it's perfect
I don't want to touch with your hands
touched the last time antha give you a
clean I don't take my word for many
times I've said that look at your hands
all over these I can eat it
Marc decided with a napkin Marc I want
to tell you something last time his mom
made a pound cake it was terrible it was
dense
fluffy moist top all the things to
describe Roland try the top try the top
[Laughter]
basketball he chipped a tooth chipped a
tooth the bottom in the middle are great
how is it he don't talk the top is
abominable Tom yeah a tire for
it's black again she claims it was
sometimes your mother said that why is
it why is it black Sam it's the way
pancakes are supposed to be no there
nobody want from me I want you to
explain you dissed a minute ago you said
you were proud of it now you're out of
this golden on the bottom oh let's not
yes no a lot of Entenmann's looks it's
black come on way to compare it to an
end it's burned I just am pieces burned
what color is this top is burned what
color is this okay whatever your mother
do when she's making cake what color she
just drinks alcohol and falls asleep
that's charged charred brown black yeah
but he said Brown the middle inside is
good the inside is very good we just
tweeted a picture of it too by the way
marks in it yeah yeah terrible this is a
tire I'm going I'm not going for the
edge she did this on purpose I thought
so too I said you really want me to
[ __ ] oh my god burn look a cake look
at the edge of this you see I'm doing
well he's trying to cut through it is
not cutting it really is a poor effort
mother's second poor effort in the
baking department yeah and the [ __ ]
shape of it is lumpy so the Elephant
Man's back yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] pile presentation is
horrible
yeah what the middle is good that you'll
enjoy the middle I have to be honest I
like the middle did you like is it
better than the last middle that's what
I wanted to ask anything is better than
the last but yeah yeah yeah I believe
you compared to the eating jello sucks
mmm the middle is not bad this time
I mean it's done more gate it look it's
not applause worthy but it's it's better
it's fine but the top the top is
nomination did you taste the top turn
here hi this isn't a part day baby it
taste that and tell me that's what a
pound cake is supposed to taste like
[ __ ] delicious no let me juries no
you're not burgers I am you can't be I
am though I'm Joyce you're acquired here
it's true fool just eat this bike and
you tell me you tell me if that's what
pancakes supposed to taste like it's
total of course it's burned yeah and he
knows it's burned it's completely burned
smoky flavor - maybe to you it's good
though so he grew up
it's like in the situation where there's
abuse you're not shocked to see your
father punch your mother because you see
it all the time that's how it is with
this cake mmm
how's it feel that somebody's retching
try it and spit it out my birthday's a
disaster no [ __ ] candles in it right
I could not eat more than three bites of
that I'll take the rest of that but give
them okay take it home with you yeah
thanks yeah there's a paper way to shock
you to your door but whether she
actually wants this backing nobody's
meeting she wants it back good there's a
little [ __ ] there's a little
receptacle right that we could ship it
to her and Indian giver
they're not if they don't like it then
she'll take it back
I kind of want to know if Dennis Falcone
likes it let's get Dennis Falcone out
sir yes please go get him got it alone
wait wait no don't you go get him Travis
you go get him because this one's gonna
poison his mind he'll talk to him yeah
that's right yeah go get him while he
was done losing me something with the
cake but hot dogs are the poison his
mouth we can steal while he's here sure
yeah you know mind no okay great hot
dogs hustling I like that good yeah yeah
he should have hustled like that for the
card that's right
that's right I think he'll probably
consider this his birthday present to
you Oh getting Danny
delegated responsibility and then got
Jenny yes true put a big bow I'm Dennis
is that we gonna give them that's not
fair the top is rough it's hard to eat
the table Michael it's inedible did you
know did you hear the crunch it's
inedible
it's a crunchy pound cake yeah Oh your
mother's kitchen should be [ __ ]
firebombed yeah Louie a suicide bomber
should run in and throw himself who
mother's oven coincidentally enough for
redoing the kitchen good what a bathroom
yeah she listens yes she doesn't like
when I tell you what she's not though
she's not a reader of recipes she's a
radio listener but she doesn't read how
to make [ __ ] good cake mrs. shitload
I'm confident that Danny's gonna like
this Danny Lee it will eat literally
anything anyways have you seen his wife
he doesn't like that stuff he he had a
[ __ ] a very big disagreement with an
old Coast over that he doesn't play
games with that that
well that's inside yeah well it's true
Daniel doesn't go for that [ __ ]
welcome denne denne denne I'm cutting
you a piece right now my friend now
Denny we would like you to try this and
get on Mike buddy what do you think
first of all you go to this market any
order to share that with him and you
move that one over what do you think of
the appearance first of all of the pound
cake it's bird okay that look like it
just does that look like a typical pound
cake no all right
dumbu you think of the taste yeah
honestly yeah yeah it's quite dry yeah
he's sound like Nixon Murray draw
checkers was a cake all right Anthony
made this his mom made it oh do you
think it top tastes burn Drew's taste
okay no it's burnt yeah cuz you
literally eat anything
yeah I would but I wouldn't need
anything like a listener sent up you got
to be careful where I do
[Music]
she tried though yeah but they take the
time does that taste good this is like a
ten pound cake look how big this thing's
yes terrible the top does not taste good
no but I'll tell you want you leave that
in the kitchen it'll be gone in ten
minutes
oh yeah I think so too I Terry Castro
but your review is free is too expensive
what's it free is too expensive for that
for that cake yeah yeah it was moist
inside yeah I would be proud of making
that but I can't cook you know what I'll
tell you what we get past the top yeah
see the inside is about as average as a
cake gets right but the top is so bad
that's right that it tricks the taste
buds and the elevates the middle oh that
actually tastes like food good hurt yeah
the bottom line is if the top was
halfway decent the middle it tastes like
dry [ __ ] right right like you need to I
need like you need you need a beverage
after that here Denny do you bring that
it you should have brought it in upside
down we clipped it you don't see the
black yeah but that's good and put for
us
gunto she was thinking about doing these
I'm sure you bring the powdered sugar
right well you Brian look and you apply
it then so it doesn't get all mushy on
the Gangnam food not a good piece of
cake yeah not a good piece this is a bad
one this was our first attempt at baking
no it's in fact her thousandth attempted
we should send a part typeface to buy a
regular pound cake and compare you just
one pound cake marks just in the mood
for some Entenmann's that's not the best
radio bit hey guys we got two pieces of
pound cake [ __ ] boo you think your
mom's gonna be disappointing to say the
least
well we are - yeah I mean I'm more upset
that you guys are just playing I think
it's great though I love why don't you
just take it Nita Carter I really do
want to throw in the garbage yeah I want
to badly haha mark can you grade my
mother's pound cake whoa marks very
hungry your ass see I haven't eaten in a
while do what Mark said flip it upside
down leave it in the kitchen
it'll be gone I'm not kidding you yeah
you're right this is going on the floor
this is good pod come on Sam
the pancake that's right he did not do
that on purpose
by the way sandwich and outside could
have offered him a piece of cake
pick it up pick it up Tyrel foam like
that use for set dressing in the funding
and I shoot did your back hurt carrying
this morning piece of cake yes we are
bringing ten more you like rippled Sam
Worthington was great me I really enjoy
talking to him yeah I respect his
opinions on baked goods yeah me too yeah
very much it's burnt this Hollywood
dreamboat things for baking his dog [ __ ]
who apparently sounds just like Ozzy
that's my accent that's my Jamaican
accent that's my European I do two
accents I do southern and it's burned
yes see the mini pearl of Paul McCartney
that's what you get right along all
right Jim and I'm glad marks here for
the big birthday celebration because you
love celebrations I do yes and we do
have some stuff I guess she do a hot dog
whoever you want hot dog I guess was
just joking so we know Anthony brought
you this [ __ ] loaf part - yep don't know
why but he did if you tried to heal the
caca as my friend the Haitian Phillipe
used to say piece de caca is a pile of
[ __ ] if you tried to put a candle into
it it would snap in it yeah a roman
candle would snap in half yeah [ __ ] a
nightmare if the [ __ ] Hill I got like
you're building a railroad a stake spike
food all right I suppose hotdog was just
kidding because hotdog does have a
presentation oh good pulling my leg yeah
yeah he wouldn't be a little hunk of
[ __ ] and not have a gift for me no
you're just kidding pretty excited about
this yeah me too I mean for somebody not
to acknowledge everything you've done
for them
[Music]
my god this is weird
it's night thank you very much for this
flower he brought you flowers they look
like flowers from downstairs it doesn't
matter where he got them the fact that
he what should I put them and put it you
put his mic on put it in the cake
they'll stay mics off what should I put
them in all right you're the first
person I ever got flowers for so thank
you what happens they're alive and you
have to put them in water or they or
they die yeah right you could put them
in the cake but they would just die in
yes they would commit suicide yeah lack
of moisture yeah maybe we should get
like a little vase this is a lovely get
what you came here in the studio I'm not
gonna carry these in the UFC podcast
right but maybe we should put these here
in studio they're lovely thank you very
much don't worry you're gonna have to
take care of them though you have to
keep them alive that's one of your
studio jobs let's take em out of the
paper and put them in a nice vaz first
time you've given anybody flowers yeah
yes aren't cheap either that's not
that's not a huge shock no not at all I
mean yeah pretty soon thank you very
much but based on your sexual history I
mean it's not a huge right no it's not a
surprise not at all no probably no
funeral
exactly I will be going to one soon oh
yeah yeah yeah come on the guy who used
to be your dad right yeah are they
yanking the plug oh no no I'm just
yeah Oh in general yeah hot dog yeah he
had a dad the guy who thought he was
just dead
uh this guy ended up in a coma he's been
in a coma for about a year and a half
yeah while he was in the coma he found
out that's not his dad oh good you visit
him before real quick Jesus I mean
unless it's a long flexible and made
lemonade there should we ask you about
your dad now or should we ask you about
your dad tomorrow cuz he did he does
have a new an update I mean I could tell
you in about two or three minutes it's
not let's do it tomorrow yeah three may
want more than two or three minutes
Ricky will be in in a little bit and
would do it tomorrow
yeah I do want to hear it yes what gave
it away the fact the guy in the coma was
Asian hot dogs not the only one
I think aleena is that right yeah
Elina has a presentation for you oh
that's very nice take it off
Alisa Alena is our intern who has
proclaimed her love for blowing guys on
the show yeah she loves to perform oral
sex on she does yes yes don't tease me
oh she came over just not the camera
overall thank you very much
coordinated at blowing dudes than yeah
okay good oh no she just sat that she's
not the camera not that over on her way
that's okay you did good but thank you
for my card what's the card say well
it's got a little multicolored dots on
the front and a little uh a tassel oh
wow and it says here's to you on your
birthday
mmm says I to the light you bring into
the world and the difference you make in
so many lives and society
happy birthday Jim and then she says
enjoy your day exclamation point
exclamation point exclamation point
thank you for making me smile every day
and making me laugh I don't have to go
to the gym I don't have to ABS oh dude a
break out because you helped me oh but
you said I don't have to abs crunch
because of you booyah abs crunch thank
you very much so you don't have to abs
crunch what do you what else do you have
I also mean your poem Jim
[Applause]
nice I know the way to my heart is true
poetry I like poetry it's common
knowledge around here so I appreciate
that that's really nice going now today
is Jim Norton's birthday he likes when
people eat his [ __ ] like it's entree
we love waking up to his voice in the
morning his huge dick should come with a
warning
Thank You bricks for Jim's parents for
having unprotected sex mad respects
happy national Jim Norton day to one and
all's don't forget Jim loves when he
touch his balls that was really great
rhyme as a poem us yes and it was
personal it really it really seemed like
she knew you thank you yeah yeah like a
hoary Robert Frost yeah
and of course our newest employee is
handsome Rob oh good you know I don't
know what he kid yeah I don't know what
he does around here but he certainly
brings up the sex appeal he's into
blowing - yeah he's super good-looking
and a kid really just he makes us all go
up a notch yeah oh yeah can you believe
that when we replaced d-bag one of the
uglier person that I've ever met yeah
one of them more horribly shaped
individual yeah he was an ugly guy ya
know Derek
Terra d-bag I don't do kind of look like
a fat lesbian okay he's like something
James Cameron so on the Mariana Trench
yeah I mean can you believe that we
replaced one of our all-time ugliest
employees with this kid look at your
toothpaste commercial thank you rob yeah
I made some cookies for you guys I won't
eat one only smells Amanda Baker always
who made them you or your mom I made
them woah
package whoa you bake too huh yeah no I
didn't know you bake Robert absolutely
Oh
oh my god you want to try one more of
course
yeah we want a whole box what we'll try
them over here who do you think you now
what's his name what's the other one's
name Anthony [ __ ] loaf yeah [ __ ] loaf oh
I'm gonna finish it off the the bite
[ __ ] loaves mom must have been cooking
for a long time right no either way in
general year Oh decades yeah that tastes
like a sugar cookie slash chocolate chip
it's [ __ ] amazing man is it just from
scratch
mr. scratch no swear to God come on this
is how good this cookie is well I would
eat your ass before I'd shake Anthony's
mother's hand when did you learn how to
bake a couple years ago I mean my mom's
always been she's a good cook Anthony's
mom yeah Wow mom is good at hiding
forensic evidence so you know
frustrating it would be if you were like
getting a you know they stick files into
cakes to get out of jail yeah came out
frustrating would it be if aunt mom made
the cake because you couldn't get the
file you just use the top or you get a
kid with a broken file tip in it pile of
[ __ ] Oh divine I'll be honest that was a
[ __ ] I had a little sliver
what a good cookie Sam Troy dig in for
Christ's sake they're so good it was
trauma strong and there's any down here
soft exactly don't get Denny in here
Louie I think hot dogs gonna like it
compare and contrast I mean so you're
living at home yeah not really doing
anything in between jobs or whatever and
your mom goes why don't you learn how to
bake no I thought you might be gay and
she said look you're gonna need this yes
okay yeah that was pretty much even now
okay no oh yeah me neither
you thought he might be alright Oh hands
me shinies dressed well he's baking what
he might be hoped he might be well let's
get a comment from I would love a
comment Travie from the taps box
the chatbox in here delicious three it's
phenomenal right unreal
I had to their breakfast happy
anniversary by the way ten year
anniversary I saw on Facebook yes I
tried to thumbs down it but nobody
wouldn't okay that's nice so uh were you
trying to get some tail
his name's Rob oh no the first time I
did it was freshman year at college for
a speech class then we had to like do a
demonstration on how to present
something or how to you know how it's
done I'm a shrink so I did how to make
cookies and and did they energy shows a
young Peter North so what's the
ingredients it's pretty much the Toll
House recipe yeah oh but I add twice as
much baking soda and I use an extra
punch of flour drug cutter make it
African women cutting up the studio is
that right any cuz I meant is it better
than usual I didn't taste it you think
no I mean the smell voiced yeah what do
you think tracksuit yeah you dressed
like gene Gotti in court okay who do you
think is a better Baker handsome Rob
yeah or is y'all kidnap Ujamaa top or
Anthony's mother yeah who would you
rather [ __ ] him or Anthony's mom I never
saw her that's how you know we're baking
stinks when a grown man goes I don't
know I never saw her
not automatically her but like I may
take the young guy who can bake if she
if she's [ __ ] not you're 9 or above I
could cook too he's a good good job man
I wish every day was Jim's birthday you
and me both but then again I don't have
any I okay bite was very good really
great job it's Anthony in there where
the nothing worse than a food segment
what are we doing he killed himself
sorry this is nice no it's good pups
no one's here
good one or the one we don't need the
one we don't need okay what don't we
need there's supposed to be somebody
else coming but they're running very
very late I don't know is it I don't
know if that's normal in the community
or not I'm sure its top to bottom where
does this take like two hours uh it took
like an hour
oh yeah wasn't wasn't too bad I haven't
made them in a couple years to do you
mean this is from memory yes it is
what can we go trade out a hot dog and
Anthony yeah I love it hot dog put your
phone down and go trade out with Anthony
no I know he is because I'd love I would
love Anthony to come in and taste what
baking historically is taste like yeah
you know Anthony will just acknowledge
it's a good cookie it's not gonna be an
exciting moment you don't think so no
we're waiting furnace for another
birthday I know but they're not gonna
show up whoever they are yeah think so
community I'm thinking of they're always
late is that right yes I know what you
mean I of course you do you do that
Dennis knows Danny right now is pinching
his shaft yeah it is and he had already
had to reach behind to do it he's
sitting on he tucked but I accident on
purpose right no it's a big one yeah
then he's all prick how was your gigs
good good busy weekend it was a busy how
many no Friday and Saturday
take it okay weddings yeah yeah I told
you I want you oh you couldn't come to
my party because I was working at a gig
where would you a wedding DJ yeah I know
that
oh nice do you like get on the floor I
don't annoy people I just you know make
sure they get up and dance
uh-huh okay you control them with the
music oh you do oh yeah like a benign
dictator I let the music do the talking
I'm Genesis a sex cult what's that I
would not be surprised if I don't it's
one blow-up doll of the [ __ ] rope
around a section much like Dennis
doesn't need a sex cult le w I mean hi
Anthony I'll have a bite of the cookie
pretty good right a middle of a hot
segment here that's not good why don't
you think so he's not used to [ __ ]
unburnt exactly look it's sweet and
moist yes you're not used to almost
dropping something and breaking your
foot undercooked
seven seven people here said I look
great they're delicious is it weird to
not hurt your teeth fighting it I don't
like the pancake that's untrue well what
what don't you like about the cookies
you walked in here just bizarre Wow it's
soft you're not used to that you're
right Travis is right yeah does not
taste to me I don't know
yeah I'm sorry Rob I mean you're right
what if it's nothing good if it doesn't
feel like a marble on your teeth like
baked it's too light no it's not burnt
your mom has warped your taste buds yeah
she has yes Jenny we need a taco unless
is a heron for somebody doesn't like to
cook he just took a second bite I know
make sure that my palate was it's
correct for someone who doesn't like the
cookie air two eight one
in the booth
[ __ ] can you imagine if we actually
did a lie-detector test to see if he
[ __ ] ate a [ __ ] cookie in the
booth how bad are segments that okay
now set up some just bland questions is
your name Anthony are you a are you a
male does your mother make cake with a
flame thrower
[Laughter]
did you eat a cookie in the office No
we'll be back damn it my birthday stinks
why surrounded by young boys and baked
goods like young boys so why is it I had
you pegged all wrong no you certainly
did yeah I mean our whole planning was
off then because that's kind of what we
yeah when we figured out I understand
yeah you just hang out with young boys
and eat cook you know I don't oh jeez
don't Wow I forget I've sent out the
wrong message that sounds like a good
time to you Marc right yeah I'll take
responsibility I've given out the wrong
signals yeah okay alright I don't know
what what did you want for your birthday
doesn't matter anybody want anything
really oh you want a young lady Oh hmm
Travis Jim wants a young lady's there
anything we can do about that yeah give
me a minute
yeah yeah go get a broad who works here
hungry [ __ ] references oh he
doesn't like their girl intern oh really
yeah I'm sorry Dennis I know you don't
like to dirty mouths no reason foul
language you don't like that you don't
like that why don't you like alena cuz
it's full she's full of [ __ ] no it's not
that I don't like her it's just like you
have to buy him back being backwards but
then I'll turn it forward had a boy what
a great I'm a company man why don't you
like Alina like I said I did I just
think she's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow
and we're I'm tired of it yeah you're
tired of oh yeah tired of it you just
write it here yeah that's a man who's
been in the trenches Danny no exactly
now you can imagine how much frustrated
I am is just this is like Matt Dillon
and the [ __ ] young cop in in uh in
crash yes you know you think you know
who you are in ten years then you know
who you are yeah
that was just like right now you just
started [ __ ] to be fair he's had to
eat [ __ ] for dessert every night of
his life
yeah how do you feel your mother's
[ __ ] peyote cake do you make oatmeal
raisin cookies I like those oh there you
go
your mother's cook your mother's cake
looks like a [ __ ] a tow that has had
something heavy dropped on its bite oh
they cut off a [ __ ] climber
[Laughter]
Elena's young girl so she talks a lot of
[ __ ] but she's fun and she's a fun
person you don't take it literally at
face value stuck in a suck your dick he
reads that as like hey she's talking
about [ __ ] and she's gonna talk my
god cuz you think that that's they're
gonna do you don't understand that like
when someone's young she's just having
fun with that she's not just gonna suck
someone's dick no just look she comes in
sorry yours
okay that's fine hey how's it going how
was your weekend good but I didn't suck
any [ __ ] this weekend I know but you
kind of committing hey I lost some money
yeah I think my mom made some shitty
desserts again exactly you know you
can't counterpoint I don't know you did
a stick thing too you brought in your
mother's cake you and this is not no
[ __ ] you knew what you brought that in
we'd mock it but it was good you
understood we thought it was gonna be a
good cake you know you know I didn't
really think it looks like a [ __ ]
aerial view of Potsie Weber head black
awful thing Oh should we bring it one
more gift
[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy somebody's smiling thank you very
much
[Applause]
and the best part is that she almost
said Johnny that was the best washer see
if you can grab that you happy - dear
joy Jimmy have a seat introduce yourself
cake deliverer good morning good morning
what's your name Natasha dreams are you
good how are you I'm a little hungover
but I'm okay get back from your travels
by the way I finally want to Instagram
you away well I did I bet you know it's
funny oh I was ill leave it there cuz in
case our guest comes in okay
we had dug in camera yes there she was
she was the first guest to do the first
in studio to do the chip chip person
podcast
she was quite fun yeah finds to him good
yes actually
excellent so how did Lanie get you to do
this Lanie what did you say to her to
sell her on coming in here just bringing
me cupcakes which is very nice by the
way for the crew Thomas loves you okay
she loves you what kind of early to get
up why then the see from my house for a
good cause
yeah James Byrd you look great yes how
is it came in my birthday soon
yeah yeah it's Jim's birthday you first
yes see we were gonna go out to eat I
thought maybe we'd go out to eat and
have a good time and have a fun chat yes
she went away yes she's uh while she's
back now I'm back she is I know it yeah
yeah it's good to be back so maybe you
can you now you'll have time to go have
a chat yeah bite to eat you know why not
right I'm not eating much now these days
but why is that Fashion Week it's coming
away and I have like a lot of castings
and other kinks and so I've just been
hardly any putts it's so hot you don't
want to eat because you feel like heavy
and sweaty and I see as streamlined as
possible what do you do professionally
runway shows oh yeah yeah yeah so I have
a couple casting
she had shoots last week as well I was
shooting actually here in Times Square
so I just been doing like my modeling
thing and you got a stay narek cyclic me
oh yeah now I are you booked as a trans
model how the hell you are okay I'm
booked as a trans model this a
transgender modeling agency that
represents me that was Emily you know
there's no reason not to be into it now
her into a book exactly well I saw a
glimpse of your gentle area to look
great you wearing shorts apparently
you're not familiar with her work I've
tried to get her to take her clothes off
I heard that too no surprises Shay mind
me that my fault I didn't I wasn't sure
no Instagram
nothing I'm new to it I'm learning I see
but I'll call you yes yes your dreams oh
you got it so you don't do any more
adult films you know what I am supposed
to shoot Madeline at post she asked me
if I want to shoot like some stuff for
my birthday next month when's your
birthday August 31st how old you gonna
be forever 21 okay just like Jim by the
way that's what I saw cut it out Sam
ripping me no I I'm 49 today it's very
depressing no it's not I mean at least
you're here to talk about it you know
that's what I've been telling myself the
whole way home on the Flyers I couldn't
sleep
Hey look oh you guys cut it out
everyone's making me feel better
yeah yeah I think I don't act 49 but so
what you know my prostate 49 for
hundreds of pop yes
I dunno I do get it checked out
sometimes I gotta go for my checks and
stuff like that I think after 14 years
detective prostate or something I pee a
lot you pee a lot I do
what's that frequent urination that's
that's a something I don't know what it
is I do I just drink a lot of fluids I
don't know a lot of words yeah I mean
you want pressure on your prostate I'm
like I can't take much of my pasta
joints
oh you like fluid and then kinetic fluid
/ oh yeah yeah who do you prefer them
all over my body
wow what a good egg you are yes
Marcus Marcus this is this is why I love
this show because mark is literally
discovering himself yes Laurens life in
1988 do you find that Natasha that a lot
of people have discovered themselves
through you and conversations and
actions yeah yeah when they come in the
gateway to the other side you are but a
nice gateway very appealing right sit
down
do you like being a gateway is that
something that turns you on right I'm
not into trans and then all of a sudden
they're right and the winner from girls
like you and Bailey Jay had that effect
on people too
we're guys like you think you know what
you like and what you but they don't say
oh wait a minute
but do you do you there's some girls are
like I never tell people I don't have to
tell people it's like I think you kind
of should tell someone I don't think
it's like I like to tell some sometimes
I don't sometimes they do it's a click
at the jaw if I'm really it depends on
the situation that I meet the person the
context and everything but like a lot of
people already know me so you're gonna
fool around with somebody like smart
yeah before that I haven't told them
really but lately no I don't has it ever
ended poorly when you haven't said
anything no not really only maybe one
time what was the one time what happened
I just got like a little smack in the
face Oh how'd they find out
well cuz they went after I gave a
[ __ ] and
after they cam oh the high was already
over there become a different person
yeah I'm a much different Jim Norton the
lamb before I come yeah different much
more reasonable Jim Norton after I come
right before I come I'll sign over my
[ __ ] apartment you can check your
more work oriented post-coitus I really
am before I come along the problem you
are yeah yeah I really am that's why
people who could do stuff with their
commerce so sociopathic like guys that
throw there come on people or shoot
they're coming to syringe or psychotic
because they have to make the decision
after they because once you've calmly I
might think of doing that like oh boy
what she look [ __ ] good with come on
it and as soon as I come like oh boy
better clean up and go home immediately
done immediately I'm back to being me
right but before you think about their
own come maybe it's a possibility you
could happen